hi this is presh talwalkar in this video
i'll teach you the mathematically best
way to play the game of memory also
known as concentration
the game of memory is played with pairs
of cards that are placed face down on
the table and then shuffled so that you
don't know the location of the cards
player one starts the game by picking up
two cards
if the two cards match to be a pair
then player one gets one point
picks up the cards and then gets to go
again
if the two cards are not a match then
player one has to flip the cards over
and then loses the turn so that the next
player goes according to the same rules
now player 2 has an advantage here if
player 2 flips over a card which is a
pencil player 2 can remember the
location of the pencil from player 1 and
then make a match
so the players play according to the
same roles and then move and turn and
try to make the most number of matches
until all the cards are gone
in this particular game player 2 gets 3
points by making 3 matches and wins the
game
now children may not remember the
location of all the cards but in the
mathematical version we're going to
assume that players have perfect memory
if they see a card they're always going
to remember where its location was
we'll also assume that players are
trying to make the most number of
expected matches and trying to deny the
opponent to make any matches
this is a zero-sum game where the gain
of one player is a loss for the other
accordingly we're going to say a match
for you is plus one point and a match
for your opponent will be negative one
point to you
the moves in the game can be
characterized by the maximum number of
unknown cards that you flip over
a two move is what you would naturally
do you flip over one unknown card you
try and match it with something if you
can
and otherwise you search the other
unknown cards to make a match so you
flip over a second unknown card
when you start the game you necessarily
don't know any of the cards so you have
to do a two move
a one move says you flip over one
unknown card you make a match if
possible and otherwise don't search the
remaining cards for the match you go
ahead and flip over a known card which
is a non-match
so let's say i flip over a dog a one
move would say don't try and search for
the match of the dog go ahead and flip
over one of the cards you already know
which is not a match
this one move seems very strange but
we're going to show why it's
strategically the smart thing to do in
some situations
a two move in this particular situation
would be to search the remaining cards
to try and match the dog
there's a final type of move which is a
zero move and that says flip over zero
unknown cards or flip over two cards
that you know which are not a match
so you flip over these two cards or
these two cards or these two cards those
are examples of zero modes again a zero
move may seem very strange but there's
going to be a mathematical reason why
you'd want to do it
so let's look at an example where you
have three pairs of cards three pairs on
the table and you know the location of
one card which is a moon for previous
play
you flip over a card and it happens to
be a turtle which is not a match for the
moon
what should you do here
naturally most of us are going to try
and search for a match for the turtle
this is completing the two move you flip
over an unknown card
so let's calculate the expected value of
trying to find a match for the turtle
there are four cards and in two of the
cases we're going to flip over a card
which is not going to match the turtle
and it's not going to match the moon
and in this case is actually very bad
for you you're going to reveal
information which allows your opponent
to win all the remaining pairs on the
table
let me show you how that happens let's
say you flip over a pencil which is not
a match for the turtle and it's not a
match for the moon now your opponent
knows the location of the moon the
pencil and the turtle and the three
unknown cards which have not been
flipped so now your opponent each time
they're going to flip over card is going
to match one of the cards they already
know so clearly within three turns
they're going to flip over all three
cards and make all three matches
but that's not the only thing that could
happen in one of the four cases you
might be able to match the turtle so
let's assume that you get lucky and one
of the four times you actually will be
able to make a match so you get one
point and now you're in a situation
where you have four cards on the table
and you know the location the upper left
is the moon so the value of this game at
this point we'll just denote it by the
variable x
there's one more thing that can happen
let's say you flip over a card and you
show a moon
now this is not going to be a good thing
you're actually going to reveal the
location of the moon which allows your
opponent to immediately make a pair
so you lose your turn and now your
opponent is immediately going to make
the pair of the moon
now what happens is your opponent is
facing four cards of which they know the
upper right hand is a turtle
so since having four cards one known was
the value of x when it was your move
your opponent having the situation of
four cards one known will have a value
of negative x to you it's exactly the
opposite because it's a zero sum game
so now we have all the information to
calculate the conditional expected value
of a two move when you're trying to
match for the turtle
if you look at the second and third
contingencies these are going to exactly
be the opposite of each other so in the
expected value calculation they're gonna
net out to be zero
so that leaves one part in our
mathematical calculation which is two
over four times negative three and that
means the expected value for trying to
match for a turtle here is negative one
and a half and that's not a good thing
it means your opponent is expected to
make one and a half more matches than
you
intuitively the reason it's a bad
position for you and when you try and
match the turtle is that you're very
likely to reveal the location of the
pencil which allows your opponent to
make all three matches
so seeing that this is not a good option
for you you might say well what if
instead i do a one move and just ruin my
turn
what would happen here what would the
conditional value be of a one move
so now if you waste your turn your
opponent is going to have six cards of
which they know the value of two of them
so let's try and calculate the expected
value to your opponent
now of those four cards there's a two
out of four chance that your opponent is
going to make a match for either the
turtle or the moon so your opponent is
going to immediately get one point so
assume they make a match for the moon
now the opponent has a situation of four
cards of which one is known
the calculation here is that there's
actually going to be a two-thirds chance
that the opponent is going to be able to
run the table and make the remaining two
matches and there's only a one-third
chance that they're going to make a
mistake here not make a match and
therefore that'll give you enough
information to make the remaining two
matches
the other thing that could happen is
that let's say your opponent does not
make a match on the first flip
so they flip over a pencil that's a two
out of four chance
now they're not going to waste their
turn because if they show the moon or
the turtle you're going to know the
location of all these and you're going
to run the table so what they're going
to do is they're going to try and search
those remaining three unknown cards for
the location of the pencil
now in this situation we can calculate
there's a conditional one-third chance
that they're going to match the pencil
and that will allow them enough
information to run the table
but there's also a two-thirds chance
that they're not going to be able to
match the pencil here and therefore that
will give you enough information to run
the table and get all three pairs
so we can put all these probabilities
and expectations together to see the
conditional expectation of one move
it turns out to be this expression
and the net result to you as the
conditional value of the one move here
is negative one third which is negative
0.33
and now you can see something
interesting
if you try and search for the turtle
your expected value is negative one and
a half if you instead just sacrifice
your turn and say all right i can't do
it it's going to be negative 0.33
so it's actually advantageous for you
right here not to search for a match on
the turtle you would actually just
sacrifice your turn and say alright go
ahead opponent you have six cards of
which two are known i'll take my chances
there are other interesting situations
in the game
imagine that there are five pairs on the
table and from previous play you know
the value of four of the cards
most of us would probably try and search
some of these six cards to try and make
matches
but a mathematical calculation shows
that's not the thing to do you should
actually not flip over any of the new
cards
the optimal move here will be to flip
over two of the known cards you already
have the zero move is the optimal move
in this position
intuitively it's because it's too risky
to flip over a new card
just like in the last example if you
flip over a new card and you guess wrong
you might actually reveal information to
your opponent which allows your opponent
to make many matches
what's interesting is that the opponent
is going to see the situation after you
sacrifice your turn the opponent faces
the same situation
your opponent is also going to say hey i
don't want to flip over any new cards so
the opponent does a zero move and
essentially the game could be considered
a draw because both of you are just
going to flip over cards that you
already know
now you can calculate the optimal
strategy in the game of memory by doing
a computer analysis of every single
position of the game
it's characterized by the number of
pairs on the table
and the number of cards that are known
to each player you can decide which move
type is going to be optimal
now there might be actually many moves
that are optimal i'm just going to list
one of the optimal moves
so early on when you have very few cards
on the table the choices are going to be
kind of obvious that
you're going to know whether to do a two
move or one move just because of your
knowledge and what's there where the
game gets interesting is when you have
three pairs on the table now if you
don't know any cards you're gonna do a
two move but if you know one card and
the three pairs on the table that's the
example we just went through you want to
do a one move in this situation
so we're going to fill in some of the
other values in this table
and
the other example we went over is if
there were five pairs on the table and
you knew four of the cards you wanted to
do a zero move which is to say you just
sacrificed your turn and your opponent
would want to do the same thing
so we can summarize the optimal strategy
in a table or we can also kind of put it
in an equation form
you want to do a two move if you don't
know any cards k equals zero or
if the number appears on the table plus
the number of cards you know is an odd
number
you'll do a one move if you know at
least one card and the number of pairs
on the table plus the number of cards
you know is an even number
finally you want to do zero move if the
number of cards on number of pairs on
the table plus the number of cards you
know is an odd number and the number of
cards you know is at least two-thirds
the number of note pairs on the table
plus one
so that condition right here is
basically saying you want to do a zero
move when you know a lot of cards are
relative to the number of pairs on the
table
so this would be a very nice way to
describe the strategy there's just one
exception to these roles
in the position where you have six pairs
on the table
and you have one known card you do not
want to do a two move you actually the
optimal move there is going to be a one
move so you have to remember this one
special case that if there's six pairs
on the table and one known card you do
one move
so the complete optimal strategy is
described by this and what's interesting
is it's described for every single
position as you remove pairs on the
board you're gonna lead to different
positions and you still use the same
equations and use the same strategy for
every single position as the game
progresses
now what's interesting is you can
backtrack and say hey at the start of
the game i don't know any cards
so given the number of pairs that are on
the table do i want to go first or do i
want to go second
the mathematical analysis shows that if
the number of pairs is 1 6 or an odd
number that's 7 or larger it's to your
advantage to be the first player
you're going to have an expected gain of
about one divided by four n plus two
in the other cases you're going to want
to go second you're going to want to say
hey let the other person go first i'll
learn some information and that'll give
b an expected gain if the number of
pairs are two three four five or an even
number that's eight or larger
in that case the second player has an
expected gain of about one over four n
minus two
so you can decide whether to go first or
second based on the number of pairs on
the table and then you can use the
optimal strategy to end up
having a gain a slight edge over your
opponent now as you can see the gain is
going to be pretty close to zero the
game of memory is actually a pretty fair
game but there is a slight edge to one
of the players
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalkar and if you like this
video please check out my books their
links in the video description